hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to security breach we
have a head
in our inventory um i don't mean that
sarcastically i mean literally we have a
damaged head
in our pocket
so i'm going to take this over to west
arcade
because that's what i was told to do
and i always do what i'm told just like
freddy
ah he doesn't always do what he's told
but that's okay we love him anyway
the big dumb oaf
hello
freddy
i think he's stuck outside the building
freddie freddy
freddy
well this is a bit of a problem freddy
because um
it's locked there
can i hop in can i hop in through that
all right fine
i'll meet you around the other side i
guess
um when they say west arcade i'm
assuming that i look at my map
i know that this is west
so the arcade on the west side
was that i have no idea
okay
so
ah
fascade
i'm assuming fazcade
that sounds about right
hey freddy
hey no no no
there is no need
man if i actually crouch it it kind of
makes a big difference
let me save and then i'll go upstairs
and then i'll go to the arcade then i'm
going to do something with the head i
don't really know i think it said that
there was some kind of repair station or
parts and services or something over in
fazcade area
nope
oh
i gotta go and hold levator
come on boy
come on you creepy boy i must stay here
i wish i could join you but after
tonight's stage incident i
am not allowed to perform
when i step onto the west arcade dance
floor i cannot stop myself
it is a programming book head to the
security office you'll find the staff
bot repair machine there if you see the
dj say hello he is such a nice fellow
okay
i really want to see you dancing
come on come on big boy fine
i guess we'll just have to live to see
freddy dance another day that's like
saying there's a saying something in a
movie where you like if you show a gun
at some point that gun has to be used so
freddie dancing is like
a gun
and at some point he has to dance
he's a dance maniac
i gotta see him dancing
they're the fortnite default dance on
the dance floor
hello
whoa
[Music]
okay when you said arcade i thought you
meant like a
like an arcade cabinet arcade
why is there a dance hall
this is awesome
that's the one thing about this is like
they put so much detail into this world
like so much
he is such a nice fellow he is not
oh hell no oh yes no maybe yes no
god that's awful
that's the worst thing ever
that i've ever seen
oh my god
okay
well that's kind of cool at least it's
sleeping
i don't know why a robot would need to
sleep but at least it's sleeping
oh
all right well i tried to say hello and
it just didn't work i'm assuming i'm
gonna need that later
okay i'll be with you in a moment
i'll be with you in a hot second you go
away
you don't need to be here can i shoot
you
nah
well that's
dumb yeah whatever
bathroom
uh
interesting
fascinating
it's just a bathroom okay you gone
bathroom
oh hi was there a closet in the other
bathroom too
i must miss that i'll go back just in
case there's something in there
huh
hi
okay
hello hello closet closet
no no closet here
i was very observant
really got to go to the bathroom hey
hey hi hi what does that do
nothing i suppose okay oh it does have
an arcade portion this is just the
coolest arcade ever
what in the hell
this is amazing
this is too good
where did they get this kind of money
even disneyland isn't this done up
what in the hell oh what are you doing
down there
i see you
or whatever
hi
these just gotta be patrolling
i'm wondering if like in an earlier
phase of oh
my god i didn't know you were going that
way
okay cool thank you
i was about to say i wonder if they had
like a longer detection whoa hey what
are you doing there chica
oh chica you know it's faster bedtime
you don't need to be here
oh this guy you keep doing the wrong
go
i mean don't go stay right there
i have to
be here
okay are you coming after me are you
going away
you better be going away yeah you better
be going away oh no okay we're fine
all right
uh i'm probably looking for some kind of
a repair
station or side room there was something
over there but i thought that was just
more arcade let me try to see what that
is no no no god no let go of me we got
issues
oh this is just a nice karaoke lounge
no you want to sing
i i know your voice is still beautiful
okay
can you see me behind this monitor
i don't think it covers michael but no i
don't
it sure don't
no
good god no
why are there so many of you all right
was this another karaoke lounge
beautiful bright whoa hey
go away
no yes
every time every time you suck
you all are terrible
god is there a way out
no
out of order it says oh my god
you know if i was a little more stealthy
maybe this would work out better for me
but i'm not what is going on here
uh
under construction i suppose
why why why oh my god
oh my god okay no cow why can't i shoot
you
another one
i keep thinking oh okay
stop
okay
whoa
head deposit of course
the head deposit
i know exactly why that exists
for the heads in people's pockets that
they carry around and just so happen to
bring here
okay
a little
oh
the west arcade was not shut down
properly some data may be corrupted
initializing startup sequence before
proceeding reset the audio manager
circuit breaker located next to the
dance floor gregory the security system
knows you are here and has locked you
out
reset the breakers and restore power to
the west arcade then you can repair the
staff head
oh
oh okay
well i remember seeing some breakers but
how many do i have to get all of them
uh
okay
all right
i feel good about that
okay
we decided to go creepy mode
you got it
huh
all right
great good
why am i back here
i was just wondering if there was going
to be a circuit breaker back here but
that would be too easy i think they're
all downstairs on the bottom floor
also oh here's one
yes no no no really
that doesn't count as one
princess quest hey it's princess quest
too
hey this was the thing that they were
talking about
why is it here
is this important
nah
okay well that's there i'm sure that
there's
oh monty you're here
i didn't know that
okay well apparently that's not a valid
circuit breaker so i'm gonna go
downstairs
run uh why
i guess to speed up my
journey
all right so i got to make my way
through all the animatronics that i just
made my way through
and uh go fix everything
as always
this rests entirely on my shoulders
well you're gonna get me okay
maybe not
okay i just gotta go the opposite way
that they're patrolling
you know i gotta say there's something
really off about all of this like
aside from the obvious uh animatronics
trying to kill me yadda yadda whatever
there's there's something off about how
this whole ordeal started with gregory
why was gregory there why is vanessa
here vanessa was said
to be a an internal hire from up high
that means someone high up in the five
nights at freddy's or freddy fazbear's
food chain
decided that vanessa needed to be here
why
and i think the the vanessa vanni
connection that's too obvious if it is
just that
oh hey then that's
too
it's too easy you know what i mean
there's something about gregory himself
that
just doesn't feel right you know what i
mean
there's something off
hey bud
and that off thing isn't these circuit
breakers who is gregory
why is gregory here
oh
okay janitorial service ah
i have a funny feeling i was already
there up at the tippy top also
oh oh
oh oh yeah i had every reason to worry
i'm sorry
oh i'm sorry is that supposed to be
entertaining
honestly if i saw that as a kid maybe i
might like it too
okay was it in this one or was it in it
was in the other one okay that's because
it was in that closet that i saw
okay
maybe this is the janitorial one
janitorial
is for me
oh my god
wha why
that's a problem
that's a big problem
okay i'm gonna gun it out the other side
do not stop me
i do not have time to be stopped why
whoa oh my god no
no
stop
please i'd rather you didn't stop it oh
my god he has sunglasses
he's got sunnies
i didn't realize that would be a problem
but it is
no no no no no i'm trying to find okay
oh god i gotta hide i gotta go hide i
gotta go hide i gotta go hide i'm gonna
hide
oh my god oh my god okay so i don't know
where the other ones are i remember
seeing some hither and tether but i
don't exactly know where they either is
or
now
okay
you coming upstairs please don't okay
all right
all right okay
okay
so they're aha aha that's one got it i
must run
jump no there's blast okay i'm going for
it i'm going
got it
whoa that's a bad idea he can see me he
can see me
i'm gonna go up the stairs and hide
right in the same place i just was work
perfect perfect okay
so that was on that i bet there's one up
tippy top
ah
there's got to be one up tippy top
because the one in the back area
definitely didn't work
okay here we go
oh it's on
you know they give me a weapon then they
take it right away
oh what is that all about oh that's not
good but you can you can at least be
shot
oh okay there must be one around here
right
there must be right oh god they are all
common for me
oh my god why why
holy shoot
is this still up there
i mean i don't know why i wouldn't be on
the ceiling but you know
oh my god
you are the worst the worst the worst
yeah i don't see any here none here none
here
right in in in thank you
oh yeah i should be using my cameras
okay what do we got i'm there i'm right
next to it
i'm literally
okay
there is a software update available
reset the final circuit breaker located
at the south end of the arcade
maintenance hallway i know that one i
know that one that was the one i first
tried to do okay but that's obviously
not the one
oh god oh god this is not gonna work yes
it will
there we go i'm actually being stealthy
about this
oh my god
okay
why who did it who did it
who did it
who did it who snitched who snitched on
me
oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god why
okay that was not fun oh my god oh my
god where oh
god no
no
god damn it
i have to do all that again
this took me a while
bear with me
as i am
apparently
very bad
i'm gonna sneak by you
okay
oh my god
why music so big
why why music's so big
oh that music's wow god damn it
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh god
whoa you were nowhere near me maybe i
was running full okay you were near me
okay i get that yeah
okay
why music so loud
okay okay okay okay
oh my god what was that what was that
should i look
is it looking good is that music
why is it so loud
oh
yeah that's why it said run before
i get it but i want to look no i don't
want to look
oh my god don't do that
oh my god oh my god
why do i keep looking
don't do that don't do that don't do
that oh my oh my god
why did i look why did i look why would
i look why would i look
why would i look
oh no
oh
no
are you
serious
oh
my god
oh my god
i wanna see this thing okay
i get it i'm running i'm supposed to run
i get that but you're not even gonna let
me look at it also how my bones
but you're not even gonna let me look at
it the most visually interesting thing
you could possibly imagine
and i'm not even allowed to look at it
and you don't even put an autosave or
nothing
i am upset about that
whoa that was too close
please get out
what
all right
oh
my god hi
i'm fine i am fine i am fine
i am fine
oh hey bud
okay okay okay okay
making it
making it whoa oh why did you stop there
you all right here we go here we
go here we go here we go
all right not looking
not looking
yeah that's so yep here we go
oh my god i have no stamina wish i could
go faster oh well oh my god
oh my god are you kidding me are you
serious right now
go do that
[Music]
wow
all right welcome back to this room
that was an ordeal for me
but you know very cool sequence
didn't want to play it 10 times but very
cool
i did like it
the first time even the second time
wasn't too bad
ultimate partios congratulations on your
installation of the new improved djmm
the djmm features eons of musical
enjoyment using a patented technique
called improv royalty free no two songs
are ever the same save a fortune on
cleanup using a series of connected
tubes the gjmm can run cleaning routines
between set lists if it if the need ever
arises activate the new bouncer mode
warning bouncer mode still under
development usa bouncer mode will void
your warranty
okay i'm gonna repair the robot head now
because that's what i need to do
hi can i deposit the robot head
it's not really a button but okay
there you go
i guess i'm done then
this is another security badge
level six
i didn't
yes i know what security badges do i
didn't even know that level six was a
possibility and no one told me to get
that i could have easily missed that
i
don't know also it's 5 30 which means
that it's like almost 6 a.m but i don't
feel any closer to resolving
anything
something tells me that the questions
aren't going to get answered at 6 a.m
all right anyway time to go back to roxy
raceway
uh that was one hell of a
detour but
all's fair
don't even think about it
nope
you thought about it and i didn't like
that
i can't
oh god no oh god no
[Music]
nope
not today ma'am
not today
that's a patented technique that i
learned with through my many iterations
of playing through this level
uh
all right but we get back to roxy
raceway and then bada bing badaboom i
meet up with freddy and i've got a bone
to pick with freddy sure would have been
nice if freddy was there to help me or
hold my hand or cuddle me or something
it would have been lovely
but alas we had to do without
i hope you got some goodies hi
freddie is there you
who's a good boy hi
what excuse do you have
better be a good one no
come along bubbe
[Applause]
come on we got a
race car to drive
maybe i don't know
sounds about as good as anything else
i think we just pop this on and then
what is the purpose of
it's to disassemble roxy right that's
the whole thing it's
trying to disassemble roxy also i gotta
say the first few hours of this
this night went by real fast like an
hour went like nothing now 15 minutes at
a time or crawling i don't know if they
paced themselves properly in uh
divvying up the hours for this night
but we will persevere
what was that
freddie get over here
come on boy
ready
freddy
come on boy
where are you
freddy
who's your good boy freddy
there he is there's fredster
all right
okay
no you come back here
where are you going
what
ah whatever okay so we got this so we
can go down whoo
so you free the better what oh my god
i hate you so much oh my god oh my god
huh
you're fake fake fake dodge bill bob
weave dodge bob weave
i did uh but i'm not a coward i'm just
better than you that's how it works okay
so before i do that on that
i'm gonna sit that better be freddy
ready say you buddy right behind me
freddy
hey there he is okay hey buddy okay so
what do we do with this
well i mean
oh
get roxy's eyes what how how does what
what what
what am i doing
what
oh i thought i was gonna ram i
oh
thanks for the
uh
i think i seem to have hit her right in
the eyes so i'm not 100 sure if uh
they're going to be intact once all
that's over
oh well that worked out quite nicely
i thought the road was all under
construction because it was all i'm down
here now
this is greg uh this gregory is uh
gregory's pretty good that's gregory's
uh
yeah your eyes don't look so good uh
i don't know if they're
all right i'll take them
one eye for me please
one second
stop roxy okay get roxy yeah you know
what
it's what it say to do so i do it
oh they're beautiful
wow
all right freddy you ready for uh
roxy vision
hey look it's the other side of this
door
that i saw
where everything was on fire
hmm interesting
interesting why is this here i don't
know but here we go oh
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay wow
you pushed me right through the goddamn
door what the hell
what the hell
holy crap
i was supposed to dodge out of the way
cause she's blind
right
okay here we go and i'm dodging
whoa oh my god
you almost had me
oh my god oh my god oh my god
distraction
die for it
there was a distraction there was a
distraction there was a
okay you're crying well you're gonna
make me feel bad
oh big loser baby crying
is big loser baby crying
[Music]
i i don't know
why are you climbing on that box
oh god oh my god oh my god i just need a
little work done
uh-huh
just oh i see i i see what i'm supposed
to do okay
right okay here i was just staring
your hair's ruined how can you tell you
don't have eyes oh everybody still loves
me yeah
uh-huh
okay
what happens if i hide in here
i am
still beautiful
yeah
still beautiful you still got it oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
why are you hiding from me
that my that oh my god
they're slow i mean i might not be out
of the woods yet
don't sniff don't worry don't sniff
don't sniff you stop that sniffing
oh my god you stop that sniffing right
now why are you hiding from me can you
please move
can you please move oh it would be great
if you moved
you're gonna just stay there aren't you
oh my god
i'm going for it i'm gunning it i'm
currently gunning it oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay
oh my god oh that's not good
where why why have you done this
i don't know why are you the way that
you are
you know
ugly
maybe if you weren't so hideous to look
at i wouldn't be running screaming from
you
okay distraction
there's a distraction over there you
should love she's
she's really locked on target
okay so
i gotta get through that door
no no no not a loser
good god
can you uh
can you blamo through this door oh my
god
uh am i bugged or something is this not
quite right i have a feeling it's not go
hang on
okay okay okay okay okay i just i did
that on purpose on purpose
because
it's not too far away from where i was
and i just
i i think something wasn't quite right
there
yeah i think she was supposed to be able
to charge you know i heard that oh my
god oh my god
oh my god
what did you heard i didn't do nothing a
follower in quickly that's what i'll do
that's what i'll do okay
okay now she's pissed
that's more what she's supposed to do
yeah that's that's that's more like it
now that's the hutzpah
oh my god oh my god what are you doing
there we go
now she's peppy she was all the bro
she was all depressed before
i think she's all depressed now
man that's sad
can you look at this
and this
could you look at that hello where'd you
go
roxy
there's uh lovely distractions for you
over there oh god
roxy
oh my god
she really don't like it when i crouch
everybody
loves me
right
you can hide
oh my god oh my forever
this is honestly
terrifying for me
oh my god where do i go
there's a vent there that i'm supposed
to unscrew drive oh god no no no no
please
you could uh not do this
i'm not hiding i am hiding
well
it's roasty toasty here
and
oh my god oh my god okay
all right okay i have the event there
there's a van that i'm supposed to open
right the vent right to the vent the
vent the vent my hair
ruined
only a little bit
singed
if you want us
still oh my god
oh my god oh my god okay hey okay here
we go and i'm through okay i'm through
you can't get through right
right okay i'm done
only a little bit only a lot only oh
incredibly i'm so goddamn good
everybody still loves me
right
uh-huh oh yeah well what if they never
loved you in the first place you ever
think about that then there's nothing to
be disappointed about because you were
already a disappointment
okay cool good talk
well hope you can't find your way out of
that pit or else i'm gonna be in trouble
good thing i'm familiar with this area
already well okay you know what it
wouldn't be security breach if it wasn't
one of the
you guys
well there's no roxy to alert anymore so
i guess it's not a big deal
freddie come on we gotta slap a eyeball
in you
maybe two if you're good
all right yeah there he is come on oh
knocked over a bone
oh
wow it fixes itself
that's fine what are you doing what is
this guy doing i'm freddy do not push me
into the security guard
do not
okay
well that was good
uh i really like that sequence you know
and i didn't mind doing that over from
the beginning because it was clear that
like i needed to do
well there and so i was happy to try to
uh
el toro the roxy there into the
obstacles very fun very cool very scary
loved it a lot
still a little buggy but you know
the jank i'm starting to embrace it
it's kind of nice
all right so we got to make our way down
to parts and services i'm assuming we
can do the same thing where we just take
the stage down
that would be the fastest so if it could
please let me do that
freddy
friday whoa freddy
there he is
oh
there he was oh he's gone here he is
ready
ready good boy
whoa why is the stage roped off no come
on there we go
that's what i thought freddy cover boy
come on come on in there you go good boy
all right another elevator ride for you
and me buddy
anything to say about that man you're
jiggly today
don't worry these balls are gonna really
sort you out
eyeballs
you're gonna be able to see so good
whoa
all right
come on freddy
whoa
you're really stompy today
you put on some weight
good thing no one ever comes down here
to bother us
all right freddie get in the tube
preparing for upgrade procedure
i'm in the protective cylinder yes thank
you
all right freddie let me get a look at
you moving freddy's face
press freddie's nose to remove skull
housing why is a child doing this
why is a child doing this i i heard the
nose thing i get it
carefully detach the ocular connectors
oh
you just went right into it
okay
click in the eyes to take them out of
freddy's face okay
easy peasy plug the replacement eyes
into the open eye sockets
okay
wow well done they don't look as pretty
as they did on connector wires okay
[Music]
okay easy
it is time to close the faceplate
is it
commence testing phase
[Music]
okay ah the eyes are moving
okay
[Music]
okay okay i thought it was gonna do more
than six my brain was already full to
bursting
okay look at that arm there
all right well that was great
thanks freddy
thank you and
bam
how are your new eyes
i am having a hard time adjusting
you look different to me
i can see movement through the walls
really
i didn't know roxy could see through
walls these are roxy's eyes well
yeah
there was an accident in the raceway is
she okay
well
nothing seems to stop her
and that's the
use rox's eye to see things no one else
can
what good news it is almost six o'clock
you will be safe now if you find an exit
but hurry the daycare attendant is loose
one last time
what
escape escape the p what what do you
mean what what do you mean what do you
mean
what do you mean what do you mean what
are you talking about colors and objects
i never knew existed nothing can hide
from me now
nothing can hot but
oh
ah
well
use an exit to escape the pizza plex but
be warned the recharge stations are
offline so they cannot protect you
what
wait hold on
hold on hold on a second hold on a hot
second hold on one hot second
hold on a heaping helping of a hot
second
hold on
stop
this can't be the end
it's not
i'm calling on that
there's still a whole monty to maim
that can't be the end
can't be
i'm gonna save this for another episode
because i bet if i go chasing an end i'm
gonna be this is gonna run on for like a
two-hour episode so i'm gonna leave this
one here and come back
if i know my five nights at freddy's
this is just a ruse
there's always a seventh hour
a seventh day whatever
thank you everybody so much for watching
i'll be back with more of this very soon
links in the description check them out
click on them they're fun
thanks for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]